yeah and spencer watkins making his
second ever big league start third
appearance of his career he was really
good in his first big league start five
innings three hits only one run he gave
up jose pokes it to right field and
that's down for a hit so abreu has a hit
two one one out in the first inning
against spencer watkins
and this is roped out to right right at
austin hayes
he'll throw in at third base
got him got him
that was
nasty
well like cedric mullins austin hayes is
a difference maker on both sides of the
ball watch him come in catch his line
drive squares the shoulders and a rocket
over to third base and there is kelvin
gutierrez applying the tag to get the
orioles off the field with a double play
they'll take their swings off of dylan
the 25 year old right hander boy he's
been good this year seven wins
top ten in the american league and total
strikeouts with 111.
mullins drops it down
that is something we haven't seen cedric
mullins do a whole lot of this season
but he is still one of the best butters
in the game and that was executed with
perfection well he's not had to do it
this year because he's been swinging it
so well at the plate for the orioles
puts this one in the air right field
deep
this one out of here
home run for austin hayes
he hasn't figured it out yet now he does
what a play he makes on defense
and he's the first one to come through
on offense the orioles go up two nothing
against cease
and there he hits mount castle
[Applause]
when it comes up and in like that
it always leaves you a little bit
concerned yeah and when it's that kind
of velocity too because at 97 miles an
hour up and in you really don't have
time to get out of the way
and you have to remember for dylan cease
he came
up and in first inning when the orioles
were in chicago and hit trey mancini in
the elbow and here he gets mount castle
oh and that's right off the left wrist
hand area and boy you hate to see that
that's where all those tiny little bones
are
so mount castle he's still down at first
base brian ebel earl's trainer out there
with him
and mount castle is going to stay in
there as he gets hit by a pinch
[Applause]
pitch from watkins is driven high and
deep
way back in the left
andrew vaughn goes yard
[Applause]
white sox caught the lead in half on an
andrew vaughn solo shot
way back there
that one is hit well
right field and rupaul two of them
for two socks
solzer got away with one he couldn't get
away with another one at three and one a
fastball right down the middle you come
at the king you best not miss and he
missed twice it is four to two
sucks
michael cope
he's going to face three four and five
in the orioles order here in the six
santander valley and urease remember
mount castle
started the game for the orioles but had
to leave due to a forearm contusion
after he got hit by a pitch from dylan
cease
[Applause]
and so you'll
face kopeck for the second time in this
series
hitched in inning
the other day
friday night struck out the side
oh yeah curveball dancing into the
bottom of the zone
[Applause]
fastball got him
[Applause]
two batters two strikeouts for kopeck
oh the slider and yet again michael
kopech strikes out the side
you'd walk with confidence to the bench
too i'd run to the bench with that stuff
and come back out and run out again a
lot of o's running to the bench
because that man liam hendricks is in
making his 40 appearance of the year 23
for 26 and save opportunities we saw him
work
and i can't believe that last number 60
strikeouts and only four walks and
opponents are hitting just 170
off the hard throwing right hand in
hendricks
billy hamilton giving a ball to a fan
there you go
[Applause]
something you'll never forget as
hamilton has come on he's going to play
left field
and then andrew vaughn shifts over to
first base
takeover for gavin sheets
up the middle by mckenna
so ryan mckenna who faced hendricks
yesterday and struck out on three
pitches he turns the first one back
around and the orioles that is their
first hit
since the second batter that they had up
when austin hayes hit the homer
and here comes trey mancini and there's
your tie and run at home plate the
worlds have just kind of hung around in
this one he's going to be competing in
the home run derby tomorrow
home run before he gets to denver
swinging a fly ball lying to right field
deep goodwin watching it is gone
it's gone
he tied the game
trey mancini starts the home run derby
early
with the line drive onto the flag court
can you believe it and the socks have
runners at first and third with two out
for adam engel
adam hits it well into left center field
mullins back it is done
another home run for adam angle
it is 7-4 socks
[Applause]
and mullins hits this one right
center field and deep but on the track
catch is made
severino will come down to score
mullins man was he close
stewart center field
angles back at the track he makes the
catch
get out of baltimore with a win 7-5 the
final score
by a couple of feet the sox take the
finale and sweep the o's for the season
well look there was a couple of long
shots in that inning but really
the boys had them all the way not much
worry and they come away with a
three-game sweep